wenn man von der ersten sekunde auf der
matte statt weiße oder jede spur
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sportplatz dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast im sportbad
frau zugführer bettina blank herzlich
willkommen
und frisch mit einer medaille aus tokio
zurückgekehrt bronzemedaille im karate
herzliche gratulation dazu erzählen mal
wie war das alter fest stand du fast fix
eine medaille noch kurz vor dem
halbfinal- kampfrichter gefühlt
der moment wo die safari hahn war
wirklich extrem emotional mit trainer
hat man quasi in der mixed zone wo marx
war der ton auf den letzten
entscheidungskampf ja es reicht für die
holzmedaille fix und
marino ganz gefasst hat neue schauen auf
die tabelle ist dort dass sie
qualifiziert bin oder nicht und der note
2 3 mal schauen müssen wo es denn echt
realisiert haben sind wir nur noch
trainer und mir beide sind uns in der
hand klagen trainer und je und hanna
klein tja also hoch emotional vor allem
weil ja die gesagt dass er so nicht so
einfach war für dich darauf kommt wir
auch gleich aber in dem moment also
wusstest du stehst im halbfinale du bist
fix podium aber du musst gleich noch
einmal kämpfen wie schafft man es dass
ich dann wirklich auf den nächsten kampf
noch zu konzentrieren im fokus zu
bleiben wenn man eben weiß ziel erreicht
mit alles fix wie geht das doch wie geht
man damit um
zum glück ist global relativ gut
gelungen ist
wohin die entscheidung körpern dass die
fixe medaille han han i sofort interview
gerne sei deshalb vario in dem orf
interview damals zerstört und während
dem interview anime noch irgendwie den
gefasst und warmer bewusst so ok jetzt
ist und zither und jetzt ist fertig mit
trainer und jetzt konzentriere - also es
ist ja sogar im verlaufe von der
interviews immer wieder gefangen hat so
war sie nun tatsächlich dass ich wisst
dann okay jetzt saniert und und ich
möchte mir das noch nicht vor doch jetzt
da ich habe mir die hand das geschafft
aber ich möchte die bühne gut verlor und
um mit einem kampf wo egal wie es
ausgeht aber nochmal alles klar das hast
du das getan wir sind als dann ganz
knapp leider nicht gereicht aber die
bronzemedaille eben erobert und das beim
debüt für dich wenn olympische spiele
aber auch für seine sportart erzählen
mal wie das im vorfeld für dich gelaufen
ist ja schon sagt das war nicht einfach
was ist genau so schwierig gewesen
ganz viele zähler aber ich habs jetzt
kurz ab es war sehr lange zeit
2016 haben wir erfahren dass unsere
sportart für
augenscheinlich 2020 das erste mal
olympisch wird
im jahr 2018 hat denn die qualifikation
begonnen und es waren sehr harte
qualifikations kriterien
also wir haben gewusst es werden für die
olympischen spiele zwei klassen
zusammengelegt
und für die spiele gibt es insgesamt nur
zehn plätze
dementsprechend war der weg verrückt und
ihre wie im vorhinein schock sagt wo man
gewissermaßen olympisch wert ist dann
ist es ja nach ich wirklich das ist
unmöglich januar im vorhinein gesetzes
druckt man fast nur durch wenn
verletzungsfrei bleibt über die ganze
zeit
und ja bei mir baden uhr vor anfang auf
oder quali oder wurm dinge dass sie
einige verletzungen ketten und nie
wirklich vor verletzung zur verletzung
wieder rufe kämpfer müssen
der narr ist einfach mal so pandemie dem
homo york aus ca und keiner weiß wie es
weitergeht und der gedanke finden
olympische spiele stattfinden sehr nett
statt es war echt schwierig damit zum
umgang obwohl das jahr irgendwo mental
kurt und jahre im jahr 21 kann ist
einfach noch nicht auf dem punkt braucht
meine leistung zum abruf und denn
so kurz vor der spiele zwei monate davor
hanni erst erfahren dass sie
qualifiziert bin das war schwierig damit
zum umgang
weile einfach so mörth und fertig war
vor dem ganze qualifikations prozess
und ihr biss sie mit auch wieder
gefangen hat und sagt er möchte
als normal versuch hat dass sie die
chance nützen und
es war schwierig weil die in der moment
1200 vor der olympischen spiele einfach
null selbstvertrauen getan dass sie
wieder normal brav und egal was passiert
bei der spiele egal was user kommt aber
ich möchte dies nütze dass sie auf der
bühne steht kann dass sie
gute kämpfer abliefern kann egal was
kommt wie wichtig ist dass selbst
zutrauen im eurosport
unglaublich wichtig immer an der
ausstrahlung
gibt was hertha und ja es entscheidet
dass sie kinder so kurz krebs trifft
ohne der reagierst du du musst
selbstbewusst auf dramatische und du
bist das vertrauen in die unter martin
die also ja und was kraft dass du dieses
selbstvertrauen wieder bekommst nach der
schwierigen qualifikations bilder oder
bist du da wieder in diesem zustand dass
an dich glauben mutig sein dich
selbstvertrauen wirst du es da wieder
hinein geschafft also es war wirklich
extrem struktureller prozess trainer und
jahrhundert wirklich eng miteinander
dezember geschafft
hat versucht an so ein kleiner schritt
zum setzer und normal an kleinert ruf
und das sich langsame steigerung gerhard
im training zum beispiel mal angefangen
dass sie - mit konzentrieren auf den
technischen aspekt auf die schnelligkeit
wenn der sicherheit kriegs denn der
krieg sicherheit im kämpfer mehr es ist
im mentalen bereich gearbeitet wo also
mag wirklich versucht jeden bereich zum
auslöser war es nur gut und das hat auf
jeden fall funktioniert wie groß war
dann die erleichterung als der quali
prozess vorbei war wie hast du dich da
gefühlt wie kann man sich vorstellen was
da ihnen durch den kopf geht ehrlich
sieht nach dem abschluss vor der
olympia-qualifikation sehr steinig man
die hans nigg schafft und iv standpunkt
dass sie mich damit abgefunden und ja
ich habe mir meinen frieden gefunden es
hat nicht so seiler und ja es hat nicht
gereicht und es war okay für mich aber
das ist dann doch anders
war ideen hat extrem glücklich aber
gemerkt was formel für einen riesendruck
von ihnen schulträger ist einfach mit
dem wissen edf bei den olympischen
spielen dabei sie und durfte seine hat
einfach die vor freude
überwog und der verlag freut dass sie
dort ca und das auch gesagt dass ganz
wenige athletinnen und athleten die
dabei waren und bei diesem debüt mit
dabei sein konnten das zeigt ja auch
dass wirklich nur die weltbesten
sozusagen am start sind jetzt warfen
vorhinein klar dass carter in paris 20
24 nicht mehr im programm stehen wird
ist sicher dazu auch ein paar gedanken
noch dazu kommen wir gleich aber wenn du
da eben ins olympische bühne ein gehst
und weist okay bei den nächsten spiele
gibt es das nicht mehr im programm es
ist nur dieses eine mal sozusagen die
möglichkeit da was macht das mit einem
sportler so dass mit ihr gemacht
hat gemischte gefühle bei mir hervor
kurve wir haben hier auf dauer city
extrem gefreut dass sie die möglichkeit
haben bei den ersten spielen dabei zum
sie auf der anderen seite macht sehr
traurig für unsere sportart ja ich
wünsche mir einfach nur wirklich
extremen dass unsere jugend mal die
möglichkeit kriegt auf so einer bühne zu
performen
die hansa bedürfe und olympische spiele
haben echt etwas magisches das kann man
nicht beschreiben und damit alle
gewinnen wahrscheinlich bei noch einmal
magisch
mehr als nur dass dabei sein aber das
hat die entscheidung bei athletin
ausgelöst und bei den athletinnen als
ihr erfahren habt okay 20 24 wird es
nicht mehr im programm sein wie geht man
damit um was denkt man sich da
es war mal definitiver großes
fragezeichen ins gesicht geschrieben
wir wissen nicht was die grüne sehen was
die die wie die entscheidungen waren
keine ahnung es war nur extrem schade
und ja und traurig wir haben vorher
gewusst wie ich es also nicht olympische
sportart und mehr hunde setzer fahrer
dürfe wie ist das als olympische
sportart ist er von unterschied wir
haben das sehr genossen das meinten den
letzten jahren diesen prozess gemeinsam
mit dem rc gehen dürfen haben und diese
unterstützung der fahrer dörfer und es
war unglaublich sonst der der
qualifikationsweg nicht möglich sei und
was bedeutet das jetzt auch für die
zukunft der sportart jetzt nicht nur in
österreich sondern international also
wie denkst du wird sich das sport und
wie kann ich mein hobby war grossartig
vielversprechend und hat gezeigt das ist
eine sportart die olympische
begeisterung auslösen kann wie siehst du
die zukunft des radsports
also unser karate weltverband wird sich
das sicher einige überlegungen mache
müsse es wird sich extrem viel wieder
ändere und mir machen einige schritte
wieder zurück das glaub ich will das mal
zurück ich konnte sehr viel ändern wenn
möglichst jahr
ich hoffe mal dass man teil
einer kleinen
professionalität wo vielleicht unser
weltverband erklärt dazu gekriegt hat
beibehält ja aber irgendwas wird man sie
ham a ha messer und in österreich
glaubst du dass deine metall jetzt auch
und die begeisterung die du durch deine
emotionen aber auch natürlich auch durch
deine kämpfe ausgelöst heißt das dass in
österreich auch etwas bewegen wird in
eurosport ist dass etwas gut du denkst
dass das passieren kann
ich wünsche mir sehr stark des ts etwas
bewirkt etwas bewegt
da du für unsere sportart für karate
österreich ich hoffe dass dies für die
richtigen wege nützen und positive
auswirkungen haben wird was hast du
schon für veränderungen jetzt erlebt in
den letzten tagen nach deiner
siegerehrung nachdem die medaille
bekommen hat nachdem so zurückgekommen
ist was merkst du hat sich dann schon
alles verändert in meinem leben
also was sich verändert hat
also ist sind mega viele termine aber
seine termine
jan
mitkriegt
wieviel loeb einfach das mitverfolgt und
wie mit kleber tun um mit klappt
animiert ist unglaublich berührt wie
viele emotional dabei waren es hat immer
vor hat nicht vorstellen könne und
dieses oder etwas olympische spiele sind
das kriegt einfach jeder mit immer
die ein so schöne erlebnisse kann ja
dieses ferien ja mehr vergesse ja wenn
man mit athletinnen und athleten redet
die zum ersten mal bei den spielen dabei
waren sagen sie auch das auf die gefahr
dass man von den eindrücken ein bisschen
erschlagen wird das vielleicht irgendwie
alles zu viel wird und dass das
vielleicht auch vom vom sport und selbst
und von der performance ablenkt wirst du
all diese eindrücke erlebt beim aller
ersten mal dabei sein
ja ja die aussage oft gehört wir haben
wir die gespannt wie es auf mich wirkt
du hast ja oft er hat wirklich nett wenn
man denkt man hat alles unter kontrolle
aber wenn man von der ersten sekunde auf
der matte steht was man scheiße oder
ihre hilfe ist gut das kann man vorhat
nicht sagen bei mir war es zum glück
wirklich so oder so sehr kann bei
wirklich großer wichtiger ereignisse hat
es geschafft auf den punkt zu bringen
und ich bin sehr glücklich dass man das
bei deiner spieler so gelungen ist die
hahn die erfahrungen was sie da gemacht
haben im dorf und alles positiv
open-air-kino großer sicherheit der werk
dazu beiträgt oder meine einstellung zum
wettkampf und das ist einfach nur rufen
ihr wollt und ruft sogar kann so viele
kann und beim wettkampf amine
performance denkt dann und dann nix
anderes und alles andere ausblenden
können
es war glaubt der knackpunkt zum
aufsaugen gab es auf jeden fall viel
positives vor allem im österreichischen
team
wahnsinnig erfolgreiche spiele und für
österreich als nicht unbedingt die
sommer sportnation ein großartiges
ergebnis also sei es mitbekommen am
rande oder was du wirklich voll im fokus
und erst nach dem bewerb was ich
mitbekommen dass viele der befragten
kriegt man das dann im team wirklich mit
jetzt mal war mega es war echt der
wahnsinn was sie dafür halten
abgeliefert herren mir war dann zu
vorjahr neun tage in cham joker in japan
als vorbereitung dort thomas klie
quarantäne quasi zwischen hotelzimmer
und trainingshalle und natürlich immer
wenn im hotel waren nicht fernsehen
trend und wir haben echt fast alle
restlichen österreichischen
medaillengewinner mitverfolgt beim zu
johanni klopp alle kämpfe dabei
vergaß dabei aber ihr angemerkt er nahm
bezug zur quelle gestern noch in abartig
stand in derselben halle und wenn ich zu
emotional war wo ich dann gemerkt bei
interviews mariadorfer später oder den
han i abschalten müsse wach im bett
kommt kommt der ist die funktion sind
jetzt nutzt brüno aprilia bola aber es
war wahnsinn also wenn man hört dass sie
gleich stadtherren und dann denkt man
sich verdammt ja ja es kommt wie knie
und simon ist so so war eng machten es
macht etwas mit einem war das vielleicht
auch etwas was die dann geholfen hat
dass da auch druckt 1000 war von der
gesamten mannschaft und dass die dann in
die karten gespielt hat gut möglich
immer wieder war gut möglich also ich
hab mir das sehr kurz gefühl denkt an
sie haben ist super job gemacht und ja
das gemeint es hat sich einiges
verändert das mitbekommen wie viele
menschen damit geführt haben die
vielleicht jetzt den krater sport so
nicht gekannt haben oder vielleicht auch
noch nicht verstanden haben aber allein
deine performance hat sie so gut
begeistert welche veränderungen wirst du
glaubst du in den nächsten wochen in
österreich noch so wahrnehmen jetzt aus
seinem umfeld aus den ganzen empfängen
die jetzt passieren werden aus den
ganzen termine die dann gesprochen hast
was glaubst du wird bleiben ich weiß
nicht was die nächste woche als noch
kommt ist sind einige termine rufen sie
mich freu
mich bei den feiern die was jetzt kommt
ist mit einer personen gemüse kann der
moment jeweils alle hinter der medaille
dort gestanden sind und mit kohl vorne
macht und tor und doch standen sind es
ist ja wirklich ein komplettes team und
wenn man medaille gewinnt ist die so
sehr in der reform also danke zum segen
weil wie oft versucht man macht mal und
tony scott netto von klöstern trotzdem
hinter ordnen und
jetzt hanni kurz der moment da sie einer
dies also hoffentlich kehrt zurück er
kann ja gibt es noch menschen die da für
dich ganz besonders wichtig waren auf
diesem weg wird somit alle da geht es
ganz viele menschen
in erster linie natürlich mein trainer
der wahnsinn ist
und ja speziell meine familie
die schöne ist der kurs nicht um
leistung medaillen oder irgendwas die
wir dann einfach nur das muss cook
gehört und es ist ja wenn man es darum
wehrt
und natürlich die ganze institution
überhaupt das ist reiche bundesheer
natürlich ist mein arbeitgeber
aber bei miro die situation dass wir
sowohl ober streiches olympiazentrum
also vorarlberg unterstützt
und damit hast du natürlich beste
bedingungen
hoffentlich auch als sportlerin in
seiner funktion um auch in zukunft all
diese erfolge vielleicht auch
wiederholen zu können was steht denn
jetzt für dich in der zukunft nach
solchen gemacht man sich auch gedanken
was die nächsten schritte sind wo bist
du dahin deiner gedanken timeline also
ich bin ja grundsätzlich ein sehr
strukturiert mensch aber ich kann sehr
gemein und kalender ist alles nur bis
zum 5 august also noch nicht bild planen
wie es mit der gott aber als des jahres
dort noch die weltmeisterschaft am plan
nun als vorbereitung hat glock noch zwei
weltcup turniere aber keine ahnung wenn
wir sind der kalender ist dann
weitergeführt
und ja es geht sehr wohl sportliche
ziele die informieren
das jahr wird doch noch einiges vor und
wieder weniger netten planung aber das
ist auf jeden fall dadurch dass du in
die wir sind ja auch sportgeschichte
geschrieben hast du bist eine von ganz
wenigen athletinnen und einen männlichen
kollegen die
olympia-medaillen haben in einer
sportart wird das auch vielleicht deine
ausgangssituation bei zukünftigen
wettkämpfen turnieren weltcups
großereignissen verändern
kann ja nur ob es mir ausgangsposition
ändert ich hoffe dass es mir persönlich
einfach
positiv stimmt dass sie
selbstbewusst automatisch stocken aber
ja
keine ahnung oder vielleicht wie sich
deine gegnerinnen auf dich einstellen
werden weil du halt jetzt natürlich auch
bewiesen hast hast du da ganz oben
das hast du vorher auch schon bewiesen
gehabt aber das in dem sinne jetzt
zementiert mit der medaille das ist
vielleicht schwieriger wird in
bestimmten entscheidungen weil sich
jetzt auch alle besser auf dich
einstellen werden
so dass man nicht überall findet man
videos also man kann nicht jeden
studieren ins detail aschauer will ich
kenne mir san mir in der tat ist der
keine ahnung aber ich denke mal wir
getan muss ich nicht irgendwas mehr
männer wie sonst es kann so schnell und
ruhig mal wieder weg also gab uns und
beim karate ob man jetzt medaille
hdf was diese gar nix also da kann
trotzdem so junger bub war der herr
koerfer und die ganz kassierer
und das heißt du gibt's jetzt auch kein
mit einem ziel aus für die
weltmeisterschaft zum beispiel weil das
feld ebenso offen ist dass man auch als
olympia medaillengewinnerin jetzt nicht
den garantierten podiumsplatz hat habe
ich das jetzt so richtig verstanden erst
recht du hast die die positiven seiten
schon aus formuliert dass du
selbstvertrauen bekommst gab es gibt
auch risiken wenn man so eine wichtige
medaille gewinnt
wie es einen selbst vielleicht zu
verändern kann was man vielleicht gar
nicht möchte gibt es dinge mit denen du
dich im vorfeld schon dingen auseinander
gesetzt also jetzt wo die medaille da
ist dass die gedanken machst du ich dann
vielleicht gar nicht eingestellt damit
an jährlich zieht noch nicht befasst
ich hoffe
dass dies mich entweder nur positiv
beeinflusst und sie damit keine
schlechte negativen eigenschaften auf
eine krähe also das wünsch magnet und
sophie dass man mein umfeld sofort
ist es auch wichtig dass man da in dem
sinne gärten ist und sofort leute hat
die einem
zur seite stehen und vielleicht eine
noch aufmerksam machen wenn sie
bestimmte dinge merken ja sich ja immer
dass ich genauso umfeld dir sagen der
gleich ins gesicht was passt und was
nicht passt und dort
ist wichtig die wir auch kurz zu deinen
anfängen als sportlerin wie war das als
du mit dem kartsport angefangen hast ich
meine der sport war sich ja noch nicht
so weit wie jetzt was hat sich dort in
diesem sport fasziniert dass du dann
gesagt dass ich möchte das wirklich als
profi machen sie war
neun jahre alt wurde mit dem karatesport
begonnen hat aber wirklich vom ersten
tag an fasziniert von ihrer sportart
damals sahen ihn eine genau so kühner
fast der grund weishaupt mal vertagt wie
sie entwickelt hat als kind doch anni
überhaupt korn leistungsgedanke kann
sein werk macht valley besser wäre volt
weil die in die höhere trainingsgruppe
wohl weil ihr neuer charakter gürtel
harald bessere barbe kein januar
begeistert im training der trainer hat
mich fasziniert die gruppe hoffmann
taugt also es war echter spaß im
vordergrund und das war für mich extrem
wichtigen leistungsgedanke ist erst sehr
spät eigentlich von mir reden nur so vor
20 jahren also da hat sich viel dahinter
im sport inzwischen und belegt muss die
jugend jetzt der hypo schon viel früher
damit anfangen zum trainieren wie
eigentlich bei mir war wohin der fahrer
hat ist gibt das sportgymnasium mit
karate war für mich klar in die
schulmusik und will unbedingt an wir
hatten das thema gary karate nun ich
glaube das war ganz ein extrem wichtiger
schritt ist schulmodell darauf dem
trainingspensum
wo im ja gerade in der indoor jahre der
pubertät mir und dementsprechend
entwickler können
und deutsch vielmehr der
leistungsgedanke co also dass sie dass
man das taugt mir taugt's reisen mit
auch der seeweg kommenden wettkämpfe und
daran ja der kampf geschickt und bis
kriegt und die trainieren und marc und
tun alles was sie kann das
wettkampfglück an und ja nur das glück
oder sie in den jugend
bewerben erfolgreich war da sie somit
nominal matura ins bundes jacobi und das
war natürlich einer der wichtigsten
schritte überhaupt jemanden mir reden da
von karate als randsportart und da war
ja fast die einzige chance dass die
leistungssportlerin wäre kann durch die
unterstützung von bundesheer also mega
mega wichtig so hat sich das entwickelt
dass sie bis heute beim bundesheer wien
und in der zwischenzeit an die denn mein
lebensmittelpunkt geändert
von vorarlberg nach oberösterreich aus
sportlichen gründen
und
wenn du sagst weiß der traum dann auch
wirklich konkret greifbar geworden bei
mir kein bestimmter wettkampf als
jugendliche als als kind vielleicht
schon wieder gesagt dass ich möchte das
unbedingt das ist der grund warum ich
jetzt wirklich ein profi sein möchte
davon leben möchte das tun möchte also
gibt es irgendeine moment wo du es
wirklich gespürt ist es geht kein
spezieller moment finde ich immer
irgendjemand form ja ich genauso gut
wäre wie die oder derjenige und mir
hat's training wieder auf turnieren wie
es die möchte einfach nichts anderes
machen ja hätte nicht anders vorstellen
könne deshalb war für mich immer so klar
wenn ihr das schafft
eine idee ist ja
ja glaubst du dass du auch in dieser
vorbildrolle für andere jetzt das
schlüpfen kannst möchtest du das
überhaupt aktiv oder
sagst du das ist das was mich eigentlich
gar nicht
interessiert also auf ganz schwer dass
sie für junge
vorbild sie kann die sich extrem wichtig
nur schon wenn die an miet zurück denkt
wie an ältere hoch geschaut haben um mir
dann einfach orientiert haben ich wollte
immer das machen und genau so wäre wie
die also sie sich mega wichtig für junge
und gewünscht dass sie die rolle
erfüllen kann und gutes vorbild für die
sie kann du hast auf jeden fall bewiesen
dass es gegen kann und ich glaube dass
du in dieser vorbildwirkung auch für
andere voll da sein kann es auf jeden
fall wünschen wir dir alles gute für die
zukunft viel erfolg und auch meine
herzliche gratulation auch von seiten
des bundesheeres zu dieser wahnsinnig
tollen leistung sind megastolz auf dich
also alles gute die rund danke dir
danke euch fürs dabei sein bis zum
nächsten mal beim sport servus
[Musik]
[Applaus]